so this is kelly and she's a destroyer a
devourer
that doesn't mean she's bad by the way
it means she's something to contend with
she's like tmx so i'm going to take her
apart
so that you can see her because you
can't unless unless you you know
happen to know what this means because
of your culture and even then you might
not be able to see it
so let's figure it out now she has eight
legs
why what has eight legs
spider how do you all feel about spiders
right and the reason you feel like that
is because you have these little spider
detectors on your skin those are
basically hairs
and when the spider crawls along in the
spider detectors
you get this creepy feeling and that's
you basically shaking your skin to get
rid of the damn spider of course you
can't do that anymore because you're not
a horse
you know so you just kind of have a
vestigial feeling like that and
spider can give you good chomping you
know and so sometimes that's actually
poisonous
and that's not so good but also a spiker
is an interesting thing from a
conceptual perspective because it spins
a web
and the web catches things that aren't
paying attention
and then the thing that isn't paying
attention gets wrapped up in this
fighter's web and then it gets sucked
dry
so that's a spider okay so she's a
spider
now spiders are pretty cool too because
they can spin webs you know and that's
the web of faith by the way that's the
web of faith
um so that's one thing she's a she's a
spider
and then well she's in this web but the
web is made out of fire because that's
fire and then
inside the fire those are skulls so
she's a spider that sits in a web of
fire and skulls
so believe me if you saw a spider like
that
you'd be looking at it you might scream
first and maybe you would run away but
then you'd come back and look at it it's
like oh look i found a spider it's in a
web of fire and skull
but that'd be very attractive to you you
probably would be able to forget about
it
and you know that's one thing about
kelly she's the bunch of things that you
bloody well cannot forget about
and so you could actually even say she's
a model of all those things that you
can't forget about
and then you could say well she's an
attempt to model all those things you
can't forget about
and you might say well why would you
want to model those things
well it's because you bloody well better
remember those things or you're not
going to stay alive
and then you might ask well should you
be dealing with the things that you
shouldn't forget about
one by one fire say
or or skeletons should you be dealing
with that one-on-one or spiders or
snakes
or should you be dealing with that as a
category
right that's the thing about human
beings is we like to deal with things
as categories because that way you can
solve a whole bunch of problems at the
same time
you know so you might say you do this
all the time you don't
if you go on online and you look at
people who are having
one advice about relationships they want
advice about relationships
and you think well really what they want
is
to figure out how to deal with this
female
or this male but they don't ask that
question
they ask how can i improve my
relationships which is that they're
trying to solve
the problem of how to relate to all the
set of all potential relationships
right now because maybe that's better
information
than exactly what to do about this
particular male
or female at this particular point in
time now often it isn't but you can
understand why
people push for that it's like why not
get the general answer
if you can then you solve the whole
class of problems
okay so what's the class of problems
here the class of problems here
is the class of problems
it's how do you conceptualize the class
of problems it's a brilliant
that's such a brilliant question you
know for
i mean maybe you can't maybe there's no
commonality between all those things
that constitute a problem
but by the same token maybe there is
well this is an attempt to do that
okay so what else about kelly she's got
a sword
her hair is on fire she also has a
headband of skulls
now people don't like skulls very much
you know
they creep us out and there's good
reason for that because all things
considered you should probably avoid
places where there are a lot of skulls
because it's easy to infer from that
that a lot of people like you died there
and that might be because there's
something around that's going to kill
you just like it killed all those other
things or there's some illness or
whatever it's like get the hell out of
there so even
chimps don't like chimp heads and they
don't like immobile chimp bodies
so you know a skull for us it's like
well you can see
it's death itself you know and it is
that but it's an archetypal symbol and
you don't get accustomed to sculpt very
very hard
so she's got skulls everywhere well
sometimes she has the tongue of the
tiger but she doesn't in this particular
representation but sometimes she does
and
that's the predatory element and the
tiger that's a pretty fascinating thing
right because it's like
12 feet long and 5 feet high you know
it's a major piece of engineering that
and probably
it will eat you so to put the tiger's
tongue on cali
also indicates that she's representative
of those terrible
awe-inspiring predatory things that lurk
in the forest because of course this is
an indian representation
she often has a snake around her waist
and usually it's a cobra
you know and cobras are another thing
that people find absolutely fascinating
like fire
and then but not in this situation what
she has wrapped around her instead are
intestines
and you see how her belly's hollow
she just gave birth to that unfortunate
character that she happens to be
standing on
and it's his intestines that she's
eating
right now i failed to see how this
symbol can protect you from death
anxiety
you know quite the contrary it seems to
me to be something that would seriously
evoke it
you know and there's no patriarchal
protection here
and i can't see how anybody could use
this to oppress the peasants
you know maybe they could scare them
with it but that isn't actually how
kelly is used so i don't think that
that's a useful way of thinking about it
at all
now interestingly enough kelly is
something you made sacrifices to
now that's cool because it's weird
people have had a hard time figuring out
the whole
idea of sacrifice so there was this guy
who was a journalist in the 1960s and he
wrote a book his name was arthur kessler
he wrote a book called the ghost in the
machine which is a book about
consciousness
and one of the things he pointed out was
that the motif of sacrifice seemed to be
archetypal it was universal it was
happening everywhere and one of the side
effects of that was human sacrifice the
gods were all upset he'd sacrifice a
couple of
slaves or captures or children because
the carthaginians used to do that all
the time
their own children and they'd have them
smile before they killed them
so it was brutal brutal but the
carthaginians they would commit suicide
at the drop of a hat because
their basic idea was if you screwed up
well you're wrong
time to kill yourself there's no hope
for you
so it's very common idea you know and
the japanese still practice that
before world war ii as well it's like so
so anyway so the whole idea of sacrifice
pretty damn dark you know
and and kessler regarded as evidence
that the human race was basically
insane like in a fundamental biological
manner that was
not fixable so it was like the ultimate
in original sin
theorizing you know and that was written
when everybody was all
shorted out about the fact that we were
going to blow ourselves up with nuclear
weapons and so
the idea that humans were basically
insane which
is not a bad theory you know you could
even say we've been driven insane by the
nature of being
anyways you make sacrifices to kelt
they're often blood sacrifices now
that's kind of interesting because
one of the things that you might notice
about what kelly represents which you
might say
is the predatory like almost diabolical
side of nature you know the part of
nature that's really working hard at
doing you
in is that it does seem to thrive on
blood
and so there's an idea here which is if
you give the damn thing what it wants
maybe it will leave you alone
but there's a more sophisticated idea
right beneath that because what happens
if you sacrifice to kelly
is she turns into her opposite and her
opposite is
well it's the opposite of this it's
benevolent nature
it's the kind of nature that
that environmentalists believe in you
know it's like
nature as french impressionist landscape
it's not mesquite mosquitoes and
guinea worms and cancer and crocodiles
and gangrene it's
you know it's it's a sunny day
old growth forest where you know disney
deer are bouncing around smiling at you
you know and that's nature too because
nature is what gives and
if you use the feminine the feminine
symbolism i mean
your mother is certainly someone who can
be an absolutely horrific force and that
often happens to infants but
by the same token she's the bearer of
everything that pulls you into life
you know and her her contact with you
her physical contact her ability to play
with you the fact that she looks at you
the fact that she feeds you directly
from her body it's like that's the whole
opposite of cali the destroyer and
they're both elements of the feminine
and part of the reason i think that it's
the feminine per se that came to
represent the destructive element of
nature as well as the positive element
is that
men experience women in many ways as the
destructive element of the feminine
because men are always being rejected by
women and women are nature
because nature is what selects you to
reproduce
and so the answer from most women to
most men is you're a nice enough guy but
there's no way your genes should
propagate themselves into the future
you know and that's as harsh as judgment
as can possibly be rendered
if you watch crumb for example which i
would highly recommend because it's full
of great mother symbolism is
he's he describes himself as someone
who's so much of a loser he's not even
in the dominance hierarchy
you know he's not at the bottom he's
outside you know so he described himself
as someone for
it was especially him and his older
brother it was
virtually impossible for them to even
conceive
of the idea that they might ask a girl
in high school out
it wasn't that they would get refused it
was that it was inconceivable that they
could even do it that's where they were
in the dominance arc
so of course crum and who has a mother
to go with it
you know all his females are like these
extremely physically powerful
bird-headed goddesses more or less and
he construes himself with this little
warped thing that's you know sort of
cowering at their feet
and it's deeply embedded and no wonder
given his circumstances it's no wonder
he actually did a remarkable job of
of developing himself in a in a
productive manner right given what he
had to go against but anyways
the idea is you sacrifice to kelly and
you bring forth its opposite now
it's i was once i thought i thought i
unders
i thought that i had come to understand
the idea of sacrifice i think i figured
this out about 15 years ago it just
blew me over when i figured it out
because
it had always been viewed either as a
kind of phenomena or something that's
pathological
but it's not it's the most remarkable
it's one of the most remarkable
conceptual discoveries that human race
has ever made
because what it meant was we started to
figure out that if you
gave something what it wanted if you
gave something
something of value then you could turn
it into something
that might be beneficial to you so
it's the it's it's the concomitant of
delayed gratification because delayed
gratification is a sacrifice
so you know the the marshmallow
experiment right
okay so you get these little kids and
you torture them you say look hey
hey you like marshmallows it's like yeah
i know you do
okay so here's a bunch of them now if
you don't eat those marshmallows
you get to have more marshmallows and so
then you leave and some of the kids eat
the marshmallows right and
you gotta admit those kids there's
something about them they get the damn
marshmallows
you know so if there was an earthquake
right then
those kids would have won okay so that's
something to think about because
delaying gratification is not always the
right answer
the environment has to be stable enough
so that the probability that you will
get what you've delayed for is high
and so if you're living in sheer chaos
you're a fool to delay gratification
it's like
eat the damn marshmallow now so so it's
not like delayed gratification is
the solution for everything it's not
sometimes it's the solution
so what do you do you make a sacrifice
now
and the idea is it will pay off in the
future so then you think about that in
architectural forms it means that
you forego something of value now
it's a sacrifice you let go of it and
the deal
is if you let go of it
better things will happen to you in the
future and you know
no other animal has figured that out
well squirrels maybe
you know because they store nuts but i
don't really believe
that they i think it's fundamentally an
instinct you know you know what i mean i
don't think they've
generalized from that idea they do act
it out
but i don't think they've generalized
from it they haven't turned it into a
concept
and so the concept here is the world is
constituted such that it has a
tremendously destructive element
but if you can barter with that properly
then you can flip it over and the part
of it that's positive
will reveal itself it's like that's
bloody brilliant
it's unbelievably brilliant and there's
even another element to it because
let's say that all your
all you've been getting from reality for
a while is kelly
it's all spiders and snakes and fires
and skull you know it's
and and things that want to eat you you
might think
why is that and one answer is well
that's just what it's like
but then that's a problem because that's
not just what it's like you know that
the opposite is there and you might say
well
where the hell is that like why is it
hiding its face from me
and one answer is
i reality is cannot be contended with
that's one answer but that's like you're
depressed and hopeless
through that always it's like you're
done here's another answer
you might be doing something wrong
and then you might think well what would
it mean to be doing something wrong
and then we might say maybe you're
hanging on to something you value a
little too tightly
maybe one of your axiomatic
presuppositions like the thing that's at
the top of your damn value structure
is actually sufficiently outdated
or pathological such that if you hold on
to it
all you're going to get is frowns and
misery
so maybe you have to let it go that's a
sacrifice and so maybe that's why the
rule is when you're making sacrifices to
kelly
okay the other god for that matter is
don't sacrifice the low quality
junk you sacrifice the stuff that you're
attached to
because if things aren't going right it
could be
that it's because you're attached to the
wrong things now that's interesting
that's starting to get very interesting
because that means that people are
starting to think
maybe my attitude has something to do
with this
something i can change maybe it's not
just the factual nature of the external
world
it's something i could contend with and
dance with and maybe if i readjusted my
moral schema
the probability is kind of low that
kelly will be there all the time and
it'll be pretty high that her positive
counterpart shows up so then the
question might be
how do we make the sacrifices that are
necessary to organize our schema of
interpretation and behavior
such that when we implement it in the
world
reality shines its positive face on us
and not its negative face
and like that's an incredibly
complicated problem right i mean that's
like that's a problem human beings have
been trying to figure out
and animals for that matter forever you
know it wasn't until they were human
beings that we started to get some
conceptual representation of it but then
the other thing too is you guys are all
doing that
you have a big bet going with nature and
the bed is
make some sacrifices right now or maybe
your parents are making sacrifices on
your behalf and what's the bet
the bet is it'll be worth it
but what does that mean it means that if
you make the proper sacrifices
you discipline yourself you don't
you're not too dissolute with your
resources you pay attention
and you wait your life will be better
well that's pretty cool because it might
be true and if it's true then
none of this is an illusion or delusion
it's just
low resolution
first pass representation
and that's smart and so you know from a
piagetian perspective well
what do you do before you understand
something you act it out
and so the people that are making
sacrifices they're acting out this idea
do they know the idea hence what you
mean by no
no they're acting it out they're
dramatically representing it
is that knowledge well it's a form of
knowledge
you know is it the kind of abstract
knowledge that we're talking about right
now
no but it's the immediate precursor to
that
you don't get from the phenomena to the
articulation without
running it through some bodily
representations and some drama
and this is so damn complicated that you
know you probably couldn't get to it
until you had
civilizations that were pretty damn good
and lots of people thinking about this
all the time you know and so the person
who came up with this
they would have experienced it as a
religious revelation
it's like what's the nature of reality
hoof you get this image you know it's of
this
multi-armed goddess and it's it's in
flames it's in a web and it's like
terrifying you
it's terrifying you you're gripped by it
and you make a representation
and part of the reason you worship it is
because the bloody thing has got you in
its grip
and no wonder because there is an idea
behind that that's so
powerful that you should be gripped by
it you should be unable to forget it
because it's a
it's an absolute it's a stellar stroke
of genius
it's a real revelation and it sets the
whole human race on the path to
making the proper sacrifices so that
the fire and the bugs and the insects
and the snakes
and the tigers stay the hell away
and a good thing it's a good thing and
then maybe now and then you know
the world's configured so that
it's beneficial to us